Speaker 1: Let's start today with a positive story
that reminds us that sometimes sometimes activism
and media pressure can actually have an effect.
Nancy Pelosi, the Democratic speaker of the House,
has done a complete 180, and she is now supporting
a ban on members of Congress trading individual
stocks. Now, this doesn't mean it's actually
going to happen. It doesn't mean it's actually
going to pass. It may. We'll have to wait and
see. But in just two short months, Nancy Pelosi,
not because she wants to, but because she was
embarrassed and pressured into it, has done a
complete 180 and has gone from. There's no reason
members of Congress should be banned from trading
individual stocks to I'd be open to it too. Let's
actually go ahead and do it. So as a reminder,
back in December of last year, just two
months ago, Nancy Pelosi was asked about this,
and she rejected the idea of a stock trading
ban for members of Congress. Here's that clip.
Speaker 2: You should members of Congress and
their spouses be banned from trading in individual
stocks while serving in Congress?
Speaker 3: No, I don't know to this second one.
We have a responsibility to report in the stock
on stuff, but I don't. I'm not familiar with that
five month review. But if people
aren't reporting, they should be. Yeah,
because this is a free market and people
and we have a free market economy that
should be able to participate in that.
Speaker 1: So that was up in December. Then
we got to January and in January, Nancy Pelosi
said, Well, I'm open to a stock trading ban
from Congress. I have great confidence in the
integrity of my members. They are remarkable.
So when people talk about, well, somebody might
do this and somebody I trust our members to give
a blanket attitude of, we can't do this and we
can't do that because we can't be trusted. I
don't buy into that. But if members want to do it,
I'm OK with that. And then the latest news is that
Nancy Pelosi is now pushing a stock trading
ban for members of Congress Axios reporting
just hours ago. House Speaker Nancy Pelosi is
moving to ban stock trading on Capitol Hill
after having consistently opposed such a measure.
This adds unprecedented momentum to an issue that
also has bipartisan support on the Senate side.
Pelosi's in premature follows building momentum
in both parties. Some progressive Democrats
and MAGA Republicans have united on a proposal
to ban sitting lawmakers from trading
individual stocks. Pelosi, who expressed
opposition in the past and some other Democratic
leaders, have been slow to take up the issue,
despite reported interest from House Minority
Leader Kevin McCarthy. So now the idea, as Axios
says, is amend the Stock Act from 2012, which
governs how members disclose purchase and sale
of stocks to eliminate the trading of individual
stocks by members of Congress. This is very, very
interesting now. This doesn't mean it will happen,
but this is without a doubt the most momentum
we've seen in this direction, and I think it
has to be restated again and again. Nancy Pelosi
doesn't want to do this. Nancy Pelosi notoriously
is involved in individual stock trading options
put. I mean, it's been widely reported. She
doesn't want this, but it is because of pressure
and essentially being embarrassed into having
to be open to it that it has gained momentum and
that's something we all did and some media outlets
have been doing. Now this is not going to be,
you know, it's not. There are some who are
opposing this on the basis that it's some kind of
oppressive, authoritarian, you know, whatever,
if you choose to run for the House or Senate
and you know, if I do that, I won't be able to
trade individual stocks. I can tell I can still
hold mutual funds. I can still own the stocks
and put them in a blind trust. This is not super
oppressive, guys, and it does make perfect
sense because not only are you in a position
to know ahead of time about events that could
impact stock prices the way we saw happen in that
crazy couple week period at the start of the
pandemic, and we saw Senator Kelly Loeffler
and others dumping stocks and buying
stocks and all these different things
on the basis of of what they presumably logically
were told at some of these pre-COVID briefings.
It's not just that you learn about things ahead
of time, it's also that your decisions can impact.
The prices of stocks now, I think if we really
want to be thorough, it's important to say
even without trading stocks. If at the time
that you become a member of the House or Senate,
you know what stocks you own, even if you can't
trade them, you can still try to legislate in
ways that would be advantageous to you. Right. So
imagine I enter the house and I know that I own. I
don't know a bunch of stocks of a bunch of shares
of Google just to make it very, very simple.
Even if I can't trade those while I am in the
House or Senate, I could still push legislation or
vote in a way that would bolster the value of the
Google stock I know I have without trading it. So
even this, which some are saying, Oh, it's too, or
it's too much too authoritarian, it's too crazy,
it still leaves itself open to sort of abuse and
manipulation due to the power that legislators
have. But it would be a big deal. It would be a
big deal. And so we're going to follow whether
it actually happens. It really makes perfect
sense. Many members of the House and Senate are
in favor of it. And the truth is, I hate to say
this, but some of them are in favor of it because
they know that there's still a bunch of ways
around it that they're going to be able to find
it. It's not just because they think it's the
right thing to do, and it's not just because
they would get the benefit of optics. It's
also because many of them have a number of
different ways around it, and the devil will be
in the details. How is it worded with regard to
blind trusts? How is it worded with regard to
mutual funds? How is it worded with regard to
the spouses or family members of those
in the House and Senate? You know,
Nancy Pelosi's husband has been a big element
of focus when it comes to her stock trading. So
many details to be sorted out. But it is a very
it's a welcome 180 from just two months ago.